Thanks.
You don't need a bag just for milk!
They put it in one.
Just say no! Pour me some, too.
Dad, want some barley tea?
Please... I'll come over.
-Thanks. Is the word processor open?
-I'm still printing.
I should buy an electronic notebook.
You smoke too much.
You could've gone to your aunt's, too.
No. Shiho wears me out.
Oh, I've got work tomorrow.
Do you need lunch?
No, I'll eat out.
The library's busy updating
to a barcode system.
I like the checkout cards better.
Me, too.
Hey, this isn't right...
What?
Did you leave out a line?
You're right!
Let me go first. I have to get this right
or my professor will complain.
SEIJI AMASAWA - JULY 5TH
This guy...
You can read, but don't stay up too late.
Good night.
I thought I'd seen that name before...
Here, too...
LIBRARY WITHDRAWAL CARD
SEIJI AMASAWA - JULY 27TH
SEIJI AMASAWA - JULY 28TH
SEIJI AMASAWA - JULY 5TH
He's taken all these books out before me.
Seiji Amasawa... What's he like?
Wonder if he's nice.